il y a comme des arômes d'amertume au
salon du vin de paris
donald trump a décidé d'augmenter les
taxes sur les vins français non
pétillants de 25% et ce depuis le 18
octobre dernier des représailles aux
aides financières accordées par l'union
européenne à airbus au détriment de
boeing est en prévision des prochaines
taxation des entreprises digital
américaine les fameuses gars femmes qui
réalisent des bénéfices peu ou pas
imposer en france et en europe
les 72 % des vignerons indépendants
français qui commercent avec les
etats-unis sont déjà fortement touchés
par ces mesures
une petite enquête dans notre réseau dès
la fin du mois de décembre c'est à dire
deux mois et demi après le début de
l'application de la taxe laissait déjà
paraître 20 millions d'euros de pertes
en trésorerie et 100 millions d'euros
sur les neuf prochains mois
voilà donc un manque à gagner important
en terme de réseau mais aussi des parts
de marché tranquillement se referme
puisque chaque fois que novell ne sont
pas vendus ce sont des vins d'autres
destinations pour ton pays dans le monde
qui prennent votre pc a contrario les
vins pétillants comme le champagne ne
sont pas encore taxé mais l'inquiétude
plane sur les gros comme sur les petits
producteurs
on est pris dans un imbroglio en plus
qui ne nous concerne pas en fait
parce que nous on touche aucune
subvention on touche rien enfin voilà là
on est on est pris au piège qu'on ait
des victimes
la conséquence c'est des pertes et puis
surtout de devoir se réorienter de leur
devoir réinvestir sur deux pays sur
lesquels j'avais pas au forcément
envisagé au départ d'un vestiaire joseph
côte nick vient chaque année des états
unis acheter du vin en france
ce caviste américain redoutent de voir
ses fournisseurs se détourner vers
d'autres marchés et surtout de perdre
ses consommateurs ces 25 % de taxes
représentent toute ma marge
cela ne pourra pas être compensée il y
aura une répercussion sur les
consommateurs
nous n'achetons plus de 20 il y aura un
impact sur les ventes et sur nos
capacités à conserver les emplois
américains et français du secteur font
front commun car ces mesures n'ont pas
du tout l'effet escompté
cette taxation en fait depuis le 18
octobre
avait rapporté moins de taxes inclus les
25% que l'année précédente avec les
importations ça ça a été le premier
point le deuxième point les estimations
économiques qui ont été faites pour les
sociétés c'est entre 85 milles et 125
mille pertes d'emplois directs
il ya déjà quelques clients qui ont
licencié une deux trois personnes mais
c'est quand même des chiffres
extrêmement important d'ici une semaine
de nouvelles taxes américaines
pourraient bien venir frapper plus
durement le marché du vin on parle d'une
hausse de 50 à 100 % cette mesure
qualifiée de désastre par les
entreprises américaines du secteur
risque d'obscurcir durablement le ciel
du monde viticole
[Musique]